maître shifu je peux là vous avez tant
le temps est une illusion
seul compte l'instant présent et là
présentement c'est bon tu doit
maintenant passer à la prochaine étape
du parcours le guerrier doit devenir
professeur je suis lui comprend
aujourd'hui a bien grandi il est
officiellement un guerrier dragon
protecteur de la vallée et je j'ai très
hâte de le retrouver parce que quand
j'ai doublé la bande annonce
je me suis aperçu qu'il allait retrouver
quelqu'un de très important dans sa vie
dont on pensait qu'elle ne le reverrait
jamais c'est son père son vrai père
s'appelle li shan qui vous je suis à la
recherche de mon fils
finalement non seulement retrouve son
père mais en plus il le retrouve toute
sa famille panda le village des pandas
bienvenue à l'abbé son système c'est
drôle on dirait mon portrait mais en
petit vous aussi mais en beaucoup plus
vieux il ya des surprises leurs films au
sens pur du terme
pau est à la recherche d'une nouvelle
partie de ce qui va composer son pouvoir
qui s'appelle le tchi et que cai le
méchant veut lui dérober pour réussir à
trouver sont il va peut-être avoir
besoin de tous les pandas de ce nouveau
village qui le découvre dans ce nouvel
opus rien attaqué la vallée qui il a
tout détruit
maintenant on va s'en prendre aux pandas
qu'il faut que tu leur apprennent à se
battre ça y est je suis très je vais
faire de vous des maîtres du kung fu
personne n'a dit que ce serait facile
j'ai été ravi d'apprendre qu'alison
miller allait faire partie du cast de
kung fu panda iii bienvenue allison pour
interpréter mais mais c'est une c'est
une jeune panda qui maîtrise le ruban
comme personne c'est ali danseuses et
elle va y à la rencontre de pau dont
elle et je pense qu elle en pince fort
pour lui
bonjour je m'appelle même mais elle est
délicieuse qu'elle voter quelle grâce
c'est très gentil peau mais je préfère
que mes admirateurs fasse ce genre de
commentaires élogieux
après la représentation arrête arrête de
me dévorer des yeux oui c'est impossible
je sais pas mais qu'est ce que la
regarder comme ça c'est le troisième
donc au fond pourrait arriver l'espèce
de recettes comme ça qu'ils se
contentent de se recycler en réalité non
il ya une sorte de parcours comme ça
initiatique qui avance de film en film
pour arriver à cette apogée qui est
contenu dans ce dont celui là et qui est
formidable
bon faut y aller là mais maître shifu a
dit qu attends tu as peur même maître
poulet il va mais c'est une poule
mouillée dit manu moi qui suis nouvelle
dans l' aventure kung fu panda jouer car
si tu pouvais m'apprendre une prise de
confus tu as préféré par exemple j'en ai
beaucoup
tu sais ça fait quand même trois
épisodes maintenant j'aime bien la prise
de doigts bouchy comme le doigt ou si la
prise de doigts bouchy ou pour prend le
doigt de son adversaire oui légère
pression et avec un mot magique et qui
déclenche le tolère de partout surtout
ici au très dangereux ce mot c'est ce
qu'a douche je peux dire oui si tu n'as
pas mon doigt dans les mains tu peux
lire ce qui douche
donc si j'ai un souci dans la vie de
tous les jours
je te fais pas de là on s'est fait peur
mais ledit adoption mais c'est quoi